so here's what happens people read
Beowulf they come across things that
don't seem like they belong to Modern
Christianity or even like let's say late
medieval Roman Catholicism and so they
say well this must be a pagan leftover
yeah so my question is well is it a
pagan leftover uh which would be fine I
wouldn't really be bothered by that but
is it a leftover or is it uh is it the
Beowulf poet using his Christianity
Anglo-Saxon Christianity right which was
his framework to try to make sense of
the world that he had had inherited from
both his Christian and his pagan
forbearers
[Music]
this is Jonathan Pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
it's good to see everybody I'm really
happy that we're kind of back into the
the schedule with Richard it's hard
because now he's becoming so busy and uh
and sadly I'm busy too but I'm really
excited we're going to talk about
Beowulf I've been looking really forward
to to this episode and so Richard thanks
for coming and you have a few things you
also want to announce because as if you
you don't if there are too many things
you're doing but that's cool go for it
that's right I just want to announce a
couple of uh pretty cool things one is
um some of some people know that I am
publishing a tabletop role-playing game
it's actually set in a fantasy world
that I've been working on for about 20
years now
um and so the role-playing game is
called emborea role-playing in the world
under Starlights coming up from strange
owl games uh in the spring there will be
a Kickstarter in April and you'll you
know you can go and you can back it you
can get hard copies PDFs all this stuff
there are going to be some levels you
know where if you back it like we'll
play a game together and and you know
like I'll run a game for you and yeah
and all this kind of stuff so
um the kickstarter hasn't lost yet but
if you want to keep up with the project
and also get in on like the play test
packets as they come out there's a
patreon uh that it's it's you know it's
not my patreon it's strange owl the
publishing company's patreon I do get
you know some of that but it's it's
their patreon
um and it's
um um so we'll put a link to that down
in as they say and then um and uh so if
if people want to follow along with the
project find out more about like what
even is this world is this a project
that I'm interested in
um at the higher levels like I said you
get play test packets character sheets
Adventures setting materials things like
that as we develop it um we just got a
bunch of stuff from uh back from our
layout artist and uh it looks really
cool and official cool so uh people will
want to check that out the other big
thing that I do want to announce is that
sometime
hopefully around when this video drops
or maybe maybe a little bit later we'll
see uh we're going to be launching a
small crowdfunding campaign for finding
the golden key so this is yeah uh this
collection of essays I know we've been
talking about it for a while
um it's finding the old golden key
essays towards the recovery of the
sacramental imagination or I'll probably
just call it recovering the sacramental
imagination because that's a little
easier to say
um uh and the crowdfunding campaign is
going to cover a couple of things I'm
not making any money off of this book
I'm just doing it because this is a
really important thing uh to me um
obviously Jonathan you've got a an essay
in this book and a lot of other people
in the symbolic World Community do as
well
um we're going to be starting a
crowdfunding campaign basically to cover
the cost of cover art which is going to
be done by uh Hugh Rose
um and uh he's got some insanely cool
ideas for how we're going to do this so
uh he's going to be doing the cover art
so we want to make sure that we can pay
him what he's worth and then also raise
money to handle things like copy editing
and type setting so so it'll be like a
small crowdfunding campaign and
hopefully this symbolic World Community
can kind of rally around we can get that
knocked out so that's the other thing
that I wanted to announce today I'm sure
I'm doing other things that are also fun
but those are the two that I'll mention
so
um we'll have links to both of those
hopefully uh we'll get that crowdfunding
campaign I got to figure out
a whole bunch of questions a whole bunch
of things that I don't know about
crowdfunding that I need to figure out
between now and whenever this video
drops but all right yeah well we we can
help you like well it's like I can give
some advice Nick this cotar is also good
yes yes yes yeah fortunately we have
people in the community who know these
things now so and my my project is going
to be way simpler than what Nicholas
just did so yeah yeah all right so let's
go Beowulf because you know I'm I'm
excited oh should we announce the other
thing that we talked about uh uh just a
minute ago
the which thing we talk about some we
talk about so many things which one are
you gonna announce uh the class do we
want to go ahead and announce oh yeah
sure go for it yeah definitely okay so
sometime this spring
um uh depending on you know when we get
the new website up and all that stuff uh
we're going to be offering a Beowulf
course through the symbolic World
um I'll be teaching it Jonathan will be
involved as much as I can rope him in
probably
um but the plan will be uh that we'll
actually read through Beowulf together
as a group it'll probably take about six
weeks to do this
um I I have a actually a class and a
curriculum that I've already developed
and taught several times but I'm going
to be adding in a bunch more of the kind
of material that you're going to be
hearing today so if you're interested in
the idea of a sort of a book club where
we read through Beowulf together and
then discuss it
um and this will include discussions of
the original language I can't teach you
Anglo-Saxon in six weeks but um but I
will do some reading from the original
language so you can get a taste and kind
of like a sense for how it sounded and
and the rhythm of the poetry and these
things
um
so that'll be uh and we're gonna do it
and there will be like a live class and
then at the end of that the lectures
will be I assume available for purchase
so yeah it's all going to record them
and then we'll and then we will sell it
as a as a course that will be on
symbolic World permanently so yeah so
this will be on the new symbolic World
site and I'm very excited about it so uh
just stay tuned for more information
about that I wanted to imagine Okay cool
so uh last time we kind of teased this
relationship between
Anglo-Saxon culture
right as we're making our way through
the uh through Universal history in the
symbolic world we tease this
relationship between Anglo-Saxon culture
and literature and uh Christian
apocryphal Jewish and Christian
apocryphal literature so I wanted to
talk a little bit more about that today
and give some specific examples uh
because
it's very clear it's very clear that the
author of Beowulf first of all is a
Christian
um
Beowulf studies is I mean Beowulf is the
in some senses it's like the most
overstudied poem in history
um because it's got so many people who
have written about it and studied it and
things like this and the thing is once
you get into it you start to realize why
it's so attractive why it's so
interesting in this
um in this way because it's a it's a
it's been described by for instance
Professor Michael drought as a textual
ruin right it's like coming across these
Rune uh these ruins a Tolkien used this
uh analogy as well coming across the
ruins of this Tower right kind of you
know and and you wanna you wanna just
like pick it apart and try to figure out
why did they you know and what's this
about and and you know you pick every
stone a single Stone you pick up right
every little
um every little Crux that you come
across in the text every little like
clearly this is not the right word The
Scribe got this wrong so what did it say
every single example of that and there
are quite a number of them in the
Beowulf poem is just sort of endlessly
interesting and fascinating and
um it's the kind of
um
at one point in my life Jonathan and
I've I've totally utterly failed at this
but I really aspired to be like the man
of one book
um I forget who's I forget who it was
that had this concept but it but
basically it was the idea that instead
of like trying to read everything you
should just like study one thing yeah go
as deep as you can possibly go into that
thing and for a long time for me Beowulf
was that
uh yeah like I said I've I've you know
tremendously failed at being a man of
one book as my
as my my office uh yeah which is mostly
bookshelves at this point uh uh can
attest but
um there's something that's really
deeply fascinating and beautiful to me
about this poem I'll talk more about
that in the course but uh what I want to
kind of argue is that the Beowulf poem
is a sort of Rosetta Stone it's a
Rosetta Stone for
um it's a Rosetta Stone for
uh medieval Christianity
and the ways that they interacted both
with this much older weirder
um Christian and Jewish tradition uh
inheritance that they that they'd
inherited and then also try to figure
out how do we fit that into the things
that our ancestors believed about the
world our Pagan answers ancestors the
things they believed about the world and
if you kind of look at the Beowulf poem
it's really got all these things in
miniature you have the conflict of
Christian and English and like Germanic
values you've got the conflict of of
um you know the religions is kind of
their underlying things as well one of
the interesting conflicts that I
probably won't talk very much about
today that seems to be going on in
Beowulf is actually a memory of an even
older pre-christian conflict between
kind of the older
um
let's say like fertility Cults which
were focused around the uh the bogs
right the bogs and then the the newer
kind of odinic religion which is focused
more around the hall right and uh focus
more on like War as opposed to as
opposed to fertility so there's a bunch
of different interesting things going on
in Beowulf and it kind of just soaks
them all up into itself but as I said
the fact that it's like this makes it uh
because it's kind of overstudied in a
way makes it an incredibly contentious
field so there's almost nothing
in Beowulf that's not up for debate by
somebody but you're gonna have Beowulf
Scholars like arguing in the in the
comments and yeah actually famously at
the University of Toronto there was a
fist fight over the dating of Beowulf uh
this isn't Canada of all places so so
there you go there you go and up and up
there in Canada land
um so there's there's there's almost
nothing about the poem that's not
debated but one of the things that isn't
debated is that it that the Beowulf poet
was a Christian yeah probably a monk
I mean certainly a monk and then
depending on when you think the poem was
written like I said very contentious
question maybe in the seventh or the
ninth or sorry the eighth or the ninth
Cent or tenth eleventh Century somewhere
in there a lot of different theories I
tend to follow the kind of the more
conservative age of B dating which uh uh
which for instance which uh was the
older belief and then it fell out of
style and now it's back in style but
anyway I like it for metrical reasons
and other things that I won't get into
today but
it's not hugely important to our
understanding of the poem
um
so you've got this Christian Author but
then what people don't really
necessarily agree on is uh to what
degree was the Beowulf poet just telling
his own story making it the story and
then to what degree was he uh taking
older stuff
and kind of uh synthesizing it working
it together and what I would basically
say is that that is a that's a weirdly
modern question yeah about a pre-modern
work right
um you know people didn't think think
about originality uh the the way that we
do today in the Middle Ages they
certainly didn't prize it the way that
we do today
um so this is you know so this is really
kind of the wrong question to me
um but the the the better question to
ask is when we when we come across
something that doesn't seem to match
with let's say for instance so so here's
what happens people read Beowulf they
come across things that don't seem like
they belong to Modern Christianity or
even like let's say late medieval Roman
Catholicism and so they say well this
must be a pagan leftover yeah so my
question is well is it a pagan leftover
uh which would be fine I wouldn't really
be bothered by that but is it a leftover
or is it uh is it the Beowulf poet using
his Christianity Anglo-Saxon
Christianity right which was his
framework to try to make sense of the
world that he had had inherited from
both his Christian and his Pagan
forbearers yeah so that's I that's what
I want to kind of show some examples of
today because uh it's a great like I
said it's kind of a great uh test case
for the way that this was done in uh in
the Middle Ages yeah so uh we talked
about this uh uh a little bit last time
about how the uh Christian Apocrypha
apocryphal literature was preserved in
Anglo-Saxon England in a way that
in a way that uh maybe it doesn't hold
on so many other places in Western
Europe part of this is because of course
England and by extension Ireland is way
out on the edge of things so even though
something like the Book of Enoch had
already been sort of I think officially
banned by the pope by this point in time
in history
um you know that this sort of like they
might not even have heard about that
band let alone there have been any way
to enforce it you know in in uh in
seventh century yeah seventh century 8th
Century Anglo-Saxon England
it's interesting because there are
there's a like what you're saying for
example the legend of Saint Christopher
has a dog-headed man it exists both in
the East and in England and Ireland
because it's as if they just have access
or they have kept certain Traditions
that have been kind of Forgotten and and
left to the to the Wayside yeah and this
includes things like uh names of
Archangels and
um
uh
other other things that that you know
that show up in like old Irish uh and
English accent prayer books I talked a
little bit last time about the Saltair
and the rain right the psalter of the
quatrains which was this uh collection
of 150 poems basically giving the Irish
version of medieval Universal history
starting with uh the fall of the Gods
starting with the fall of the devil and
his angels and how humanity is intended
to take their place in the heavens right
that they're these empty Thrones that we
are destined for right that's
you know right there at the very
beginning and by the way that same
understanding of the fall of the devil
is in the Anglo-Saxon Genesis so there's
an epic poem retelling got it right here
on the Shelf there's an epic poem
retelling of
the Book of Genesis
um the the the the old English were were
real uh they were real keen on the Old
Testament I think that they found a sort
of kinship in the stories of the Old
Testament in the
um not just not just because like
there's a bunch of violent stuff that
happens in the Old Testament but
um but really because I think that there
you know this this idea of there's
something really fundamental
specifically about Genesis that that
this this is this is how it all came to
be right in fact in the in Beowulf this
is the song right this is the song that
the shop sings the scald or The Bard
this song that the show sings in uh the
Hall of herat which anger is Grendel
it's the song of the creation of the
world it's the song of Genesis right
well you can think about how did they
tell the story of Genesis right how did
those accents tell it well it starts out
with the story The Tale of the fall of
of the devil the Devil Falls and now
there are these empty Thrones and that's
the story of the creation of the world
that's the story of Genesis that's why
we're made is to is to sit on those
Thrones right so then you can start to
see why Grendel who as we're going to
see in a moment is
um somewhere between a demon and a man
um you can see why he would be angered
by that kind of a song right so there's
lots of really interesting stuff like
this
um and of course there's an Old English
poem called Solomon and Saturn which has
a bunch of details for which The Book of
Enoch is probably the ultimate source
maybe maybe or maybe not the original
Source but uh I'm just saying all this
to say I think there's every reason to
believe that uh the author of of the
Beowulf poem either had access to the
Book of Enoch or just uh a kind of
access to this
homiletic tradition based on enokian and
apocryphal literature that was really
common in uh really common in England
during the Middle Ages so
I'll give a couple of examples of that
right so first of all we've got Grendel
so for people who don't know the story
of the Beowulf poem uh come come to my
class but for people who don't know the
story there are three monsters there's
Beowulf or not sorry there's actually
Beowulf is the fourth monster that's
kind of the actually the the hidden yeah
story but
um he's the fourth Monster uh but but
he's the good monster right um yeah um
in fact sometimes the the poem will in
Old English will use the same language
to refer to Grendel on one page and then
you turn a couple of pages and now that
same monster language is being used
right
um
um I should say that Beowulf himself
probably has an origin in something like
a fairy tale or folklore as a character
um uh there is a there's a very kind of
common folkloric Trope uh in European
stories called the bears sun tale right
and so the bearish sun tale is
um basically the idea that this woman
has relations
uh with a bear and the resulting child
is mad is a man but also kind of
bear-like right he's way too big he's a
little too hairy he sleeps a lot he eats
too much
um and basically he's just a nuisance to
everyone nobody likes him nobody wants
to uh you know and he sleeps too close
to the fire and you know just this idea
of this big slow stupid hibernating bear
and then uh and then one day a monster
shows up that nobody else can can kill
nobody else can fight and the Bear's son
saves everybody and then they they're
like oh now I kind of I see your worth I
understand your worth now
um and there are relics of this kind of
story in the Beowulf poem so after
Beowulf has killed Grendel and gretel's
mother for instance he goes back home
and we're told and this is the first
time we're told this because
the Beowulf poet doesn't uh he doesn't
give us information in a linear fashion
he's a he's a very careful Storyteller
um and so when he goes back home we find
out that actually before he left
everyone kind of thought well you know
glad we've gotten rid of him like you
know
um uh because because he was such a
nuisance and now he comes back and he's
this big hero and everybody kind of
realizes maybe we were wrong about this
guy no there's there's that kind of a
thing going on in the story uh hence all
the kind of monstrous language that's
used about Beowulf interesting but go
ahead but there are three three months
you said there are three monsters like
yeah so they're three monsters Three
Monsters the first is Grendel the second
is Grendel's mother
um and the third one is the dragon the
dragon now modern retellings uh I'm
looking at you grant Morrison uh this no
it's not Grandma Neil Gaiman Neil Gaiman
wrote that why did I confuse those two
weirdos I don't know like how could you
yeah how could I yeah yeah so modern
retellings look here's a look at you
Neil Gaiman but not just his others as
well have tried to connect these
Monsters by you know like saying oh
there were relations and then the dragon
is bit with sun or hothgar son or like
you know all this stuff but it's not
like that in the poem and uh I don't
obviously I don't like that retelling uh
but but for a couple of reasons not just
because it's not you know the original
or something but because it really
mistakes what the monsters are and what
they do in the story but uh in any case
so The Three Monsters Grendel Grendel's
mother and the Dragon
um Grendel and Grendel's mother are uh
probably the one of the closest
connections that the Beowulf poem has to
the Book of Enoch so uh they're uh they
are first of all Giants they're referred
to frequently throughout the poem as uh
as being giants like normal words for
Giants uh you know illen which is normal
Anglo-Saxon word for giant Fierce which
is
um kind of like means like a troll or a
marsh troll or you know like what's the
difference between a troll and giant
well not not really a whole lot for
purposes of the story that we're talking
about here yeah
um but also Grendel is frequently
referred to as a demon the language
that's used for him is the language that
is used to describe uh that's the
language that is used to describe uh uh
demons and evil spirits and other
English acts in literature
um Grendel of course is a um uh he eats
humans but he doesn't just eat humans he
drinks blood yeah right so he likes to
rip the head off of uh uh rip the heads
off of people
um famously Beowulf's retainer Han show
which by the way means glove a glove is
a hand shoe so anyway some guy that some
guy with the name glove uh he gets uh
gets his head ripped off and Grendel
drinks his blood
and um and this but this this sort of
cannibalistic blood drinking activity is
one of the the attributes one of the
things that is described about the
Giants in the book yeah
um so uh uh so there's there are
similarities there but the similarities
go beyond this so when
um uh when uh Beowulf is is uh
meditating on the Fate
of Grendel and the Doom that he's going
to uh you know the eternal torment that
he's going to experience he quotes this
passage that is basically just a few
lines which are basically uh
a line from The Book of Enoch para uh uh
paraphrased into Anglo-Saxon verse right
talking about talking about the um
the uh
uh the Eternal judgment that will
fall upon this Evil Soul
um and so it gets even a little more
complicated because uh first of all in
the Book of Enoch or sorry in in the
Beowulf poem we're told
that Grendel is the descendant of Cain
but one of the major themes of the poem
is this idea that the flood this is also
an idea very clearly found in the Book
of Enoch for instance the idea that the
flood was sent
uh to to the world primarily to destroy
the Giants right everybody the the old
Scandinavian old Germanic peoples
had this memory as well this memory of
the war between the gods and the Giants
right and um and so
the uh the bill of poet is able to take
this this knowledge that as Germanic
people they have that there was this war
with Giants and is able to take that and
combine it with his his knowledge of the
same war with giants from the scriptures
but of course it's not explicitly
spelled out in uh it's not in Genesis
it's it's like you said it's in the
enokian traditions and right yeah yeah
um and uh
so you you get the question and somebody
somebody sent me this question in an
email recently and I said well I have to
listen to the next episode and the
question was well if
the Giants were destroyed by the flood
then how is Grendel the descendant of
Cain
and how is this is Grendel a uh like how
is he like a giant how is he like one of
the Nephilim or whatever like if he's if
he but there's a harder question than
that which is why in the Bible like
right it's there's two places where the
word Nephilim is used one is used in in
Genesis and one is used uh in in the I
think it's in Deuteronomy when they come
up to the land of uh of the of the of
the uh at the when they come up with the
two spies right yes right yeah in front
of jail
and they it says they are of the
Nephilim those are the two places so
it's like the same question the anakim
and all these other Giants are said to
be nephilims or how do you it's the same
question like how do you how does this
work why are there still Giants After
the flood why are there still Giants
over the flood and then uh are the are
the descendant of Kane thing is the
descendant of Kane thing is that
mutually exclusive
with the idea of being like a Nephilim
or a giant like you know like the two
like the the hypothesis versus the
Nephilim hypothesis or whatever so we
actually find pretty good answers to
both of these questions in the Beowulf
poem oh really okay so first of all
first of all
um we're told that all these different
monsters descend from Kane very common
kind of a uh uh medieval theory about
the origin of like fairies elves uh Orcs
goblins you know all these things
they're all bad guys as far as the
Beowulf poet is concerned he's a
hardliner as an old professor of mine
might say he's a hardliner when it comes
to fairies
um but the the way that they
um but the way that then that this this
similarity to or this dissent from Cain
is used in the Beowulf poem uh if you
start to pay attention to it you start
to realize that it's not really a
question of like lineal uh let's say
genetic descent yeah right but the the
way that it's used and the reason that
it's important to the poem
is because
Kane was a kinslayer yeah so in
Anglo-Saxon society and like the society
let's say the Germanic Iron Age
um
to be a kinslayer
is the worst possible sin
right in a in a very similar way and I
think for a very similar reason
that uh for Dante in The Inferno the
worst possible sin um and I I mean I
lead a book club through Inferno every
Friday night for like several years now
or not necessarily through Inferno
through the whole comic comedy um and we
just finished Inferno a couple of weeks
ago
and what we see for Dante and Inferno is
that the worst possible sin is betraying
your lord betraying your master and what
both of these things have in common is
that for their respective societies for
Dante's and for the Germanic Iron Age uh
these relationships are the are the
relationships through which society
coheres
um if you cannot trust the bonds of
kinship right if if you can't even trust
your brother or your cousin or your
uncle right if you if you can't even
trust the bonds of kinship then really
how are you going to survive as a people
how are you going to survive as a
civilization this is actually one of the
big questions you know that is raised at
the end of the poem as um
uh Beowulf is the last of the yeah it's
right he's the last king of his people
right and um and you know the the the
woman you know singing his funeral dirge
one of the things she sings about is
like well now who's going to fight for
us who's now now who's going to uh
uh you know defend us and so if you
don't if you can't trust a kinship uh
and then what that does is it makes like
things like succession and things like
that really unstable and really
uncertain and Society Human Society
simply ceases to cohere so for this
Society
that and then on generosity being
ungenerous you know Hoarding in other
words like a dragon this is why the
dragon is uh dragons don't always hoard
gold they hoard gold in anglo-sax in a
Germanic Society because gold is the
thing that you need to uh you give to
your retainers right a king gives gold
to his things and his things give
service to him in return and it sounds
the same as saying I'm paying you for a
service but they didn't think of it that
way yeah and actually the thought about
it very differently than that right it
was always the idea that you know the
king is in the English accent language
he's the ring Giver he's the one that
you know breaks off the gold rings from
his chain and gives it and the idea is
he's supposed to be giving it with an
open hand and if he doesn't if he starts
hoarding the gold
then
Society starts to collapse so these are
kind of the two worst things and these
are basically uh the two kinds of evil
that we see exemplified by the Giants or
by the monsters right we've got the
Giants or the trolls or whatever you
want to call grendela's mother who
um exemplified this kinslaying right and
also the the kinslaying and the idea of
the blood Feud which was just tearing
through Germanic societies at this time
um and then with the dragon you have the
idea of hoarding right the hoarding the
event so in Grendel how are they you
mean in the sense that they're cannibals
is that what you mean by their
kinslayers like do they do you say kin
do you mean that they're killing humans
like in that way so they're they're they
are called the kin of cane and then
they're compared to and sometimes
explicitly sometimes in a subtle way to
other famous kinslayers in the story
okay so there are a number of human kin
slayings and also you know men betraying
their masters and things like this in
the background that
um that are so that when we read those
stories and when we see these things
happening sometimes it's foreshadowing
um uh hrothgar is the king of the Danes
his Hall is eventually going to be
destroyed by uh by a civil war
um and which is a thing that really
happened and people reading the poem
knew it had happened but this poem is
set before it happens and so there's
like all this ominous foreshadowing
later on there's um this awful you know
War uh that involves kinslaying and
betrayals of alliances and all these
other things with the swedes and the and
the Yates and all these different people
so the the point is that
um you know C.S Lewis when he talks
about fairy tales he says uh that they
wear their insides on their outsides
right and so Grendel and his mother are
in a way they're they're manifesting
they're making
um
they're bringing to the surface the the
kinsling the blood Feud and everything
else that's really uh like the big evil
or or represents one of the great evils
that uh has to be dealt with in Germanic
Society yeah and so uh when we look at
this uh you know the other question is
well how are there more uh so so
so to answer the question like how is
there still a line of Cain After the
flood right well
it's very simple if you the way that you
become a you know from the line of gain
the way that you become a monster is by
doing what Kane did yeah like him right
be you know becoming a monster right the
way that you become like demons is to
participate in their works yeah and it's
really interesting because there's other
uh Germanic literature for instance Old
Norse sagas in which you literally have
people actually become a monster in a
like a very literal transformative sense
yeah
um by uh you know for instance this one
guy abandons his comrades because
they're being attacked and so he just
takes all the treasure and he jumps
overboard and they never see him again
but there's this big sea serpent like a
dragon like that haunts that Bay from
that point forward so it's like well
that's that's him yeah yeah yeah yeah so
so that kind of a thing
um as far as what's interesting about
about this like and I've been because
I've been pondering that I knew the the
some of these Traditions like I know the
baby poem
well enough not in any way close to you
but because I was always interested
about the way in which
because Kane is both is a kinslayer but
he's also a civilizational figure like
he brings civilization
um and so there's a there's an
interesting there's awareness about Kane
and there's also awareness about Giants
themselves which is that there's a
duality to the Giants one is the jide as
an image of the of the civilization the
tyrannical civilization or the you know
the this this kind of Oppression from
above you know the demons kind of come
and rape women or or or impose their
order uh but then there's also the
degenerate aspect of the descendants of
Cain which is the hybridity monstrosity
chaos cannibalism you know broken
causality you know in some ways it does
represent in general when I talk about
how the modern world is it is like a
separation of Heaven and Earth so the
extremes manifest together right this
kind of extreme of tyranny and the
extreme of chaos and broken reality uh
happen together but in the Grendel poem
there isn't a sense that the that the
Giants represent an old civilization or
that they represent you know a
civilization that was there before us or
something like that I mean that's
definitely there it is there okay uh
when when
um
when Beowulf goes to uh goes goes into
hell actually
um we'll maybe talk about that in a
moment but when he goes down into the uh
the the lair right the underwater of of
Grandma's mother the troll wife of
Grendel's mother
um he finds in there he finds this sword
and the sword was forged by the Giants
okay
um and it was like this it's like this
huge sword it's better than any sword
that bill has
um one of the uh one of the sort of
tropes of the bear sun tale is that uh
the weapons always like his weapons
always break because he's too strong
yeah and Beowulf like throughout the the
story just constantly breaks swords um
it's like three or four times
um but uh it's uh but it's bigger than
any sword that he's ever held and uh but
what's really interesting is that uh is
that actually sort of inscribed on the
sword right are is the is the actual
legend of the the Giants in their war
with God from The Book of Enoch so so
it's the idea that you know this is a
technological Marvel a technological
wonder which is actually a result of
giantish civilization but that's what
actually allows beowul to kill Grendel's
mother is when he uses that sword which
himself had made he uses it to cut off
her head whereas his own sword what
hadn't been up to the task yeah I mean
that's interesting also because it's
interesting because if you think of the
whole problem that I always talk about
this problem like the idea of how death
how death fights death and how death
kind of stands at that limit and to
understand Noah as also a civilizational
figure right know it build the ark and
so it's like if if technique comes
through Kane's descendants Noah appears
as this strange figure that seems to be
able to bridge Kane and Seth because he
takes techne and he uses it to survive
the the flood and often it's there's all
these weird ways in legends that you
find that they try to bridge it you know
they'll say that he married Nama triple
Kane's sister like there are ways to try
to show that Noah Bridges the two sides
in some ways and he has to in order to
survive but it's interesting to think
that he uses the the giant sword to kill
Grendel's mother yeah yeah so that's
what he uses and then of course like her
blood uh eats away at the blade so
there's nothing but the hilt left yeah
uh when he when he comes back up to the
surface um
so this is I mean there's there are a
lot of other interesting similarities
that go deeper on the connection between
Grendel and his mother and the Giants of
the Old Testament uh so maybe one
question when you sound the sword it
says that it is the story of the Giants
revolt against God as in The Book of
Enoch how close is it to
the book of enochina
so glad you asked Jonathan I'm so glad
you asked because I can reach up and get
grab this book um so actually this is my
own uh translation of Beowulf oh wow um
I wrote this out by hand uh along with
the uh it's actually that's the see if I
can
show you here I mean this is how a
fanatic I am about studying this like
basically it's like it's like an inner
linear thing but then I have like notes
about a facing page
because there's like two different
passages I should have had these ready
to go but in one of them crothgar
kind of like contemplates uh he's
looking at it way after the fight and he
kind of like looks at it and uh
contemplates the blade
um
and like remembers the the blade yeah
yeah so it says
um on them West
so on that sword was uh uh was the
origin in written or engraved
of ancient Strife when the flood slew
when the flood of uh when the flood
destroyed
um
with uh with the rush of the ocean
the race of the Giants
um they terribly they fared terribly
that was an estranged race uh that race
was estranged to the Eternal Lord
um that was their final reward when the
waters surge
uh the ruler gave so like the the the
the the ruler of Heaven that is God gave
them their final reward with the surge
of the waves
um
so uh and there's some references to it
elsewhere in the poem
um I don't want to like spend the whole
day just playing around through this but
um I mean I do but not on camera
um but uh you know the point of this the
point of this is that the uh
um
the Beowulf poet very clearly
understands the flood as being
um mainly God's judgment against the
race of the Giants which is a very
common ancient Christian understanding
pretty much everybody regardless of
whether or not you believe in a
satellite hypothesis yeah you don't know
they need the Book of Enoch to have that
yeah you don't totally need the Book of
Enoch to have this
um to kind of to kind of show out like
like draw out a couple of other
similarities though I think the really
strong linking uh there are a couple of
strong links to to the Book of Enoch uh
from the Beowulf poem either either
proof of a direct link or maybe as I'm
going to talk about in a moment uh this
may be like a case of vernacular uh
apocryphal literature which the
beowulfport had access to that doesn't
survive but the bill poem does there's
some other example examples of this I'll
talk about in a sec
um so there's a couple of things there's
the name of Grendel himself
um so the grand is a pretty easy thing
to explain it's a perfectly good
Germanic uh on sounds like grind
um not hard to understand the L at the
end of Grendel's name oh right that it's
Michael it's Gabrielle Grendel yeah it's
not just them I mean like you've got
every pretty much every single one of
the the the uh the the leaders of the
Fallen Angels who mate with Mortal men
in the Book of Enoch
um they're all like uh
uh uh tamiel and ramiel and Daniel and
Ezekiel and Barack yeah LCL and you know
all those different yeah so I mean
that's uh that is a difficult there's no
way to prove that Association without
like a bit of linking like a missing
link that doesn't exist for us but
it's not a normal English accent ending
for a name it doesn't yeah and in some
ways without without the without the
notion of the Book of Enoch where the
names of the Fallen Angels follow the
structure of the biblical names for the
Angels it's like there's a bit of a
there's a bit of a missing Gap where you
would be hard to jump from naming your
fallen angel with an l and understanding
that this is related to the archangels
or the different names of Angels in the
in the Bible so this is a this is a
connection which it would be difficult
to absolutely prove yeah but
um but I think like my intuition is that
there's something here
um but the even stronger Association is
probably Grendel's mother right so if
Grendel is associated with the Old
Testament Giants we would sort of maybe
reasonably expect
um that his uh his mother is going to be
associated with like the daughters of
men right
um
uh what's really interesting is that in
uh the Greek translation of the Book of
Enoch
uh we are told
that uh the the daughters of men who
interbreed in this way are turned into
sirens
right uh well a siren as it was
certainly understood by people in you
know the English accent world is a water
monster right a solitary monster who
um
uh you know this is probably related to
like the the the the Hebrew word that's
associated with Lilith uh you know
that's King James translates it like a
screech owl it's that kind of a word but
in the sort of understanding you know of
you know let's say medieval England by
the time by English accent time
um this the idea of the siren was this
sort of
um uh
uh cannibalistic solitary female water
monster the siren is yeah and you find
this you find this like for instance you
know some of the church fathers
reference sirens in this in the same
kind of a context right
um so uh there's a there's there's some
support to this in the beowulfone
because in the Beowulf poem she's
referred to as meru with uh like a mere
wife uh literally a c maiden or a c
woman right which is exactly how you
would try to express the idea of a siren
yeah Anglo-Saxon
um and so uh there is a
um yeah for sure all our image views
related to water he has to go down into
the water and so you can you can like
you can kind of keep teasing This Thread
and chasing the thread and maybe we'll
look at this more in the class yeah
um but there is a very strange uh
there's a very strange passage that
refers to you know the Danes get really
desperate they can't fight Grendel they
can't get rid of him they pray to God
nothing seems to be happening
and so they revert to
demonic sacrifice
they start sacrificing to the demons
they fall back into idolatry which is a
very interesting thing because of course
the bill of potent is perfectly well
that this is happening in pre-christian
times Christianity hasn't come to the
north when this homicide prothgar is a
historical person
um we know pretty much right where he
lived where he lived all that kind of
stuff so and and of course the the
Beowulf poet knew that as well so to set
the events in his chords right that's
you know that's kind of nailing down a a
date to when this story is supposed to
be happening and
um and it's before way before any of the
Germanic people started to convert to
Christianity
and but what's really interesting is
that the the bill of poet wants to
present them as kind of virtuous pagans
right in this uh in this way that
there's not going to be room for in
Western Christian theology later on but
maybe at this early point there is
um this idea that that you know there
there were sort of virtuous you could
say like monotheistic pagans who were uh
you know or they're before the time of
Christ but they're still worshiping God
you know they're they're trying to you
know trying to seek God trying to
worship him in the best way that they
know how yeah right I mean you see
images of that in the early Christian
apologists right that's how they talk
about right yes I mean yeah this is this
is a pretty it's a pretty common
Christian idea
um
and this is how the Beowulf poet tries
to portray frothgar and and the Danes um
except that as a result of this they
fell back into idol worship and
sacrifice to Demons because they can't
beat Randall basically yeah because they
can't be Grendel and the interesting
thing is that in the Book of Enoch this
transformation of women into sirens is
immediately followed by a prophecy that
Giants would somehow lead men or cause
men to start sacrificing to Demons in
this way so this same kind of a pattern
that unfolds in in Beowulf is is
established there in the Book of Enoch
but it's not explained how it's
um
um you know I have a question like when
before they fall to demon worship you
know it's at the a pray to God and
nothing doesn't work what is the term
they're using for God in this case like
what is the what what is what do they
what's the God what's God to them
there's a really
um uh robust vocabulary
uh that's used to refer to God in
Anglo-Saxon literature I'm typically
speaking uh he's usually called like the
Lord the Eternal Lord uh the Lord
Almighty almighty god
um you know there's there's like there's
like this is pretty robust vocabulary
but um but it's it's very you know it's
you you can look at that he's using
church words basically it's
unambiguously okay of the of the
scriptures and of like like the Old
Testament scriptures in particular they
like they like using Old Testament uh
terminology to refer to God even when
they were talking about Christ uh
especially like Lord of hosts Lord of
ours right that kind of stuff very
unambiguously CR you know Christian
language yeah
so this is this is just something so
there are some some ties here now um
there are some other examples of of
apocryphal literature coming up in the
Beowulf poem uh the other one that I'll
just kind of talk about real quick and
maybe tease a little bit
uh comes up in uh comes up in the
depiction the description of hell
um or or really The Lair of the of the
of the mirror wife the layer of the the
she troll of Grendel's mother
um and it's very famously there's this
description of how it's a really graphic
it's really scary it's really it's
really you know dark
um a really beautifully written out in
um
uh really really beautifully kind of
written out in uh alliterative verse in
a Beowulf poem and uh people have
noticed for a long time they've noticed
that this description of hell is almost
the same or identical to the one that's
given in one of the blickling homilies
so I talked last time about the idea of
a homilary right um that most people
most priests in medieval Europe were not
expected to be great homeless or great
preachers themselves I sometimes think
it'd be maybe good to go back to this
model like take a little pressure off of
of the priests you know
um and and this will sound weird to
Protestants who are listening to this
because like your pastor's main job is
to prep a sermon but actually that
wasn't the main job of the priest the
main job of the priest was to uh say the
mass and comfort the sick and the dying
and you know he had uh you know presided
over baptisms and weddings he had a lot
of uh sacramental duties uh uh and and
so for him the the you know you being a
great preacher was not the main thing
you were looking for uh in a pastor
and uh and you know many of these men
didn't have a very high level of
Education
um and so what they the way that they
handled this was that they had there
were called homilarities and homilary
was basically a collection of homilies
structured usually around the church
here so it'd be like a homily for every
Sunday that you'll have to preach this
year and then also a um uh homily for
like major feast days when people would
be coming to church and you would want
them to hear a good sermon and in one of
the blickling homilies uh there are a
bunch of beautiful ones I'd love to
mention I probably mentioned it before
but it Bears mentioning again for
instance one of the blickling homilies
um uh refers to the mother of God as
God's Own Arkenstone
um which if you've read The Hobbit the
Arkenstone right is this precious stone
at the the center of the mountain but in
um
in Old English means uh uh it can mean a
pearl it's very often used to translate
uh Latin Margarita you know Pearl and
then also sometimes used to uh it's also
sometimes used to refer to religious
relics right so the idea of the mother
of God is like a pearl you can
understand but also the idea of her as
like a reliquary right or God's Own
reliquary right yeah which you know so
like it's easy to understand that um uh
pretty beautiful but it's a beautiful
connection to The Hobbit uh so anyway
um so yeah so uh but in one of these
homilies homily number 16. you get this
description of hell I'll read it real
quick because it's not very long that
well I mean the PO the homily is kind of
long but I'll just read the end yeah
but now let's bid the high Angel St
Michael so this is a it's a homily for
michaelness uh the for St Michael's day
now let's bid the high Angel Saint
Michael and the nine orders of the Holy
Angels that they may be an aid for us
against hell foes uh hellfo by the way
very common term that's used throughout
the poem for Grendel and his mother
um they were holy ones uh they were the
holy ones for the taking of The Souls of
men so Saint Paul was looking in the
northern region of the world uh so this
is now referring to uh an apocryphal
work known as the Vizio poly uh the
vision of Saint Paul or The Apocalypse
of Saint Paul
so Saint Paul was looking at the
northern region of this world where all
the waters dropped down and there he saw
over that water a certain horror Stone
remember that they put the they put uh
the Germanic people put hell in the
North in the extreme North First sort of
obvious reasons
um uh over that water certain horror
Stone and north of that stone very
frosty Woods had grown and there were
dark Mists and under that stone was the
dwelling place of nikors and Weirs uh
nikor is a kind of a sea monster
and uh Bill fights like a bunch of
nikors in the Beowulf poem I said there
were three monsters there's really like
three big monsters and just a bunch of
little ones and he saw that on the
cliffhung on the icy trees many black
Souls Bound by their hands and their
enemies in the likeness of nikors were
grasping at them just like the greedy
wolf and that water was back was black
Down Under The Cliff and between the
cliff and the water was about 12 miles
and when the branches broke then those
Souls that had been hanging on those
branches fell and the nikors seized them
these then were those Souls who would
unjustly sinned here in the world and
did not wish to stop before their life's
end but now let's bid Saint Michael
eagerly eagerly that he lead our souls
into Joy where they might Rejoice always
Without End in eternity so what's being
referred to here is that individual poly
at least in this particular version of
it there's actually a few different
versions of it circulating and
ultimately it's connected to the uh the
life of Adam and Eve and all this other
literature
but uh in the visual poly uh Saint
Michael the Archangel is the one who's
leading Saint Paul through the afterlife
right um and it's actually I mean this
is a Proto text for the Divine Comedy
there's no Divine comment about this
kind of literature
um so the so St Paul is or the Archangel
Michael is leading uh Paul through and
showing him hell and showing him the
tortures that await the wicked and
you'll notice it's not fire here it's
being frozen and falling you know and
frosty icy Cliffs and being eaten by
water monsters and all these different
things right this is a very distinctly
kind of Northern Germanic vision of hell
um so what's really interesting about
this is that in this and in a couple of
other places uh the Beowulf poet
will reference this homily or reference
other things about Saint Michael the
Archangel and never explicitly
because of course uh because of course
the uh the people he's writing about the
Danes at the point they're not
Christians they don't know anything
about Archangel Michael
and and the bail foot is pretty careful
about not allowing his characters to
know things that they wouldn't know if
without without the Revelation let's say
yeah right and so he's like very careful
about this even like very mundane things
right he's very careful about the flow
of information
he's he's I mean really artistic really
really good storyteller
um but
so so this is the thing there are these
little Archangel Michael references
throughout the poem
uh but but he never can can uh mention
him specifically and so for a long time
people thought just thought oh well he's
doing this thing here where he's
referring vision of Hell from a homily
he'd heard and now he's putting it into
his poem well maybe that's what happened
but actually uh the more recent evidence
for reasons I won't go into right now
they have to do with uh textual findings
and things like this
is that um is it actually probably both
the blickling homily and the Beowulf
poem are referencing the same
uh
vernacular translation of the Vizio poly
so there was an endless Action
Translation in the vernacular that they
were both borrowing from and uh later on
later on it's lost and uh so all we have
is these borrowings but we don't have
the vernacular version itself but you
can go on and look at the uh uh the
connections that are being drawn and um
there's a really brilliant essay uh that
basically posits
um without you know just reading the
whole essay to you here uh there's a
recent essay that's come out really
beautiful that basically suggests that
the reason that the Beowulf poet poet is
used is making all these subtle
Archangel Michael references in the poem
which his audience would certainly have
understood so at the same time that he's
making these references to the Archangel
Michael he is also making references to
uh to
um uh the the the dragon slaying of
fafnir which is like the great
prototypical Germanic Dragon slang story
okay so he's consciously drawing this
connection between the great Christian
dragon slayer uh which is of course say
Michael
um or at least he's one of them and then
the great Pagan dragon slayer right the
which varies a little bit depending on
the vision of the story sigured or uh or
Siegfried depending on how old the story
is but point is
point is that um he's
he's drawing these connections between a
great Christian dragon slaying story or
serpent defeating story and then the
great Pagan serpent defeating story
and he's com he's drawing Connections in
the minds of his audience uh to Beowulf
to the to his main character to his
protagonist who is not quite a pagan
yeah but also not quite a Christian you
know and he gets the end of his life uh
Beowulf has this sort of a speech where
he's you know at the very end of his
life he's he's been you know Feist the
dragon spoilers kills it with some help
um uh but it's poisoned and is about to
die so as he's as he's dying he kind of
he's talking to weglaf his um his young
Kinsmen and he's kind of going over
you know his life and talking about the
things that he did the wars that he's
fought the monsters he's killed uh the
way that he's ruled his people into his
old age all these different things and
he's kind of like contemplating
basically whether or not he's gonna make
the cut right he's got no certainty of
Salvation you know through the
sacraments or through Christ or through
the confession of his sins but what he
says is
I never fought against my kin I never
betrayed any of my loyalties I never
right you know I was never stingy with
my things right all these things that we
talked about that are like these are the
worst possible sins in this context this
is the work of Cain
Beowulf who is you know sometimes the
sort of monstrous or ambiguous figure
especially early on in his life comes
the end of it and says uh he rejected
all of those things and so because of
this the king of heaven will have no
need to uh uh to punish him right so it
says the king of Heaven
uh it's the king of heaven or Lord of
Heaven I mean yeah something like that
yeah like I said there's there's a lot
of but I mean it's it's very clearly you
know for both the poet and the uh for
both the poet and also for the audience
yeah they know who they're referring to
yeah it's very clearly
yeah and it's an interesting it's an
interesting like if you understand it
subtly like this this this subtle poem
where people could both
let's say
nostalgically
participate in the ancient story but
then also have a kind of a grip of
sadness to see like he's not like he's
he's on the and because of the lack his
lack of because he's not a Christian
it's like what does it mean you know how
what how do how can we understand this
like there's a there's a kind of a deep
a very a very deep uh sentiment there
that's happening so this is what's so
interesting and complex and beautiful to
me about the Beowulf poem and I think
why I'm so deeply attracted to it is
because the Beowulf poet is I mean the
story that he tells is very sensitive
it's very it it handles this question of
like our righteous Pagan ancestors and
all these different things right handles
it all with a great deal of delicacy
um it seems like sometimes maybe he's
trying to make a uh like to censure or
condemn certain aspects of like the old
Germanic paganism right the the blood
Feud and the where Guild and all this
different stuff but he's NE he never
comes out as far as like totally
condemning it
um to and to this day peop you know
students read the the poem like if they
really read the poems half of them will
come away thinking this is a celebration
of these old heroic ideals and the other
half will come away thinking that he oh
no he's condemning these things actually
he's not really doing either he's maybe
uh kind of pointing out some of the
problems but also it's clear
uh that he's passed the test of love
that he loves the thing that he's
writing about and he loves the the kind
of story that he's telling and so he's
he never
he never comes out quite as like
condemning the old ideal of Northern
courage but maybe also ultimately says
but this isn't really it's not enough
you've gotta you've got to move on from
this now
um so it's a really beautiful poem and
um I think like I said you know I've
given just a few examples here there's a
lot more and if some of the stuff is
murky I apologize to the audience um uh
some of the stuff is like well if you
gave me two hours or I could give you
like 20 pages to read then then then you
know I could I could get you all the way
there but
um hopefully this will be enough to kind
of tease connections for people uh and
they can start to see a way in which
um you know a lot of the stuff I'm
saying is only groundbreaking in that
in the past when people have read the
Beowulf poem they come across things
like
uh sort of like a plurality of divine
beings you know which you find at the
beginning of the poem uh mentioned in
the same breath as kind of this idea of
a monotheistic biblical God
and this is the come across stuff like
that and say well Christianity doesn't
have anything like this in it because
they're thinking in terms of modern
Christianity or maybe sometimes like
really late medieval uh Catholic Roman
Catholicism Christianity and so they
they say well Christianity doesn't have
this terminology and it doesn't have
this vocabulary it doesn't have these
ways of thinking about the world so this
has to be
paganism that's still like lurking
somewhere in the poem and uh in if you
believe that then basically the poet
doesn't know what he's doing because uh
because then it's just like a really bad
Stitch job
um and my argument is that that's not
the case um that the poet is actually a
supremely careful and gifted poet he's
striking this really delicate balance
between you know paganism and
Christianity this apocryphal literature
the Old Testament scriptures all those
things come together beautifully in this
poem so
if that sounds like your thing and you'd
like to know more about it um and
specifically to hear the reading
available from this particular
perspective uh which really not a little
there's scholarship out there but as far
as like in a classroom setting you're
not going to get that pretty much
anywhere
um
sign up for our class
yeah definitely I mean I definitely uh I
want to be for sure I wanted us to do it
together if we can because yeah I find
it very exciting you know I read they
were for a long time ago and I remember
exactly the problems that you're saying
which is you know because you can't it
was hard and you read it in your 20s you
always start to read it with a
commentary because it's so difficult and
so you end up with that perception which
is that this is some but I remember when
the very first time I read it and I read
this idea of description of of Cain and
the Giants and the flood and thinking
you know what I think this guy
he knew what he was doing and so it's
like as we kind of understand more and
more you know the the mythological
language of Christianity and we're kind
of rediscovering it I think that that uh
that it's going to be clear and clear so
thanks thanks Richard thanks for doing
the work man it's just so amazing thanks
for having me I uh like I said I I
sometimes I come to the end of these
things I'm like man that was kind of
muddled and I hope people you know are
able to kind of piece that all together
because in you know I've I mean I
literally this whole shelf right here to
my right uh is about half just either
commentaries on Beowulf or translations
of it um or or like different versions
of the original text like I just you
know for years and years I've just
collected the scholarship on the poem
and um deeply interested in it and
sometimes my uh my brain gets ahead of
my mouth and you know I don't say
everything I intended to say but
hopefully this is a good introduction to
the poem and people will check out the
class so yeah definitely so everybody
pay pay attention and uh and of course
our discussion with Richard will
continue so thanks Richard all right
thanks Jonathan
thank you
this episode is part of a series of
discussions I've had with Richard Roland
on universal history you can find a list
of all these episodes on my YouTube
channel where you can find them also in
my podcast stream from the symbolic
world on your different podcast
platforms make sure to check out
Richard's second podcast which you hosts
in collaboration with Father Andrew
damick called amen Soul which looks at
the relationship between Tolkien and
Orthodoxy this podcast has also inspired
in me some ideas for creating some
images whether it be the king Under the
Mountain whether it be the Grail or
beautiful Ethiopian Traditions I've
created some products which you can find
on my store the symbolic world.store and
it will probably be more of those to
come very soon so stay tuned this
conversation is ongoing and there is
still very much to explore in the
Universal history